[Music]
[Applause]
so here is an argument consider a
subject a person in any statement P this
can be anything now P entails the
following any evidence against P is
misleading
we're misleading as meant leads to a
false conclusion right because I mean if
P is the case then any evidence against
P is misleading - if he knows that P and
a knows that the entails Q and on the
basis of such knowledge a concludes that
Q then a knows that - there are
philosophers who have denied that Q
holds in general but these are special
cases about philosophical skepticism if
one didn't generally accept - and
thought that it was usually R in general
wrong one might criticize someone for
the fallacy of giving a valid argument
for a conclusion and of course that is
the heart in general fallacy so if we
know some premises and we know what it
entails then if a concludes that q than
a knows that q suppose the subject a
knows that p and those two are really
all we really need is the two is true
right then a knows that any evidence
against P is misleading
note that the argument applies to any
evidence arising now or or alleged
evidence right we should really say
arising now or in the
future this already may seem very
strange that just by knowing some common
or garden variety statement which I am
calling P and this can be more or less
anything you like right one knows a
sleeping thing that any future evidence
against P will be misleading but of
course that does follow from P itself we
might have also have as a general
principle so this is something else now
right though it is very hard to state in
a nice rigorous way especially giving it
the necessary generality if a knows the
taking in action of type T leads to a
consequence C and a wishes above all
else to avoid C that is that this is the
only relevant issue and there are on
counter considerations or whatever then
a should resolve now not to take any
action of type T this too is a very
sweeping statement but we are
considering the case where a knows at a
certain time that if she does anything
of a certain kind in the future it will
lead to a consequence that she thinks is
bad there being no other relevant
consequences which would override it for
example suppose she knows that if she
opens the door someone outside is going
to shoot her it would be a reasonable
thing for her to resolve not open the
door so she should resolve not to take
any action of type T let the action of
type T be accepting evidence against P
that is doubting or
eyeing the P on the basis of some future
evidence the consequence C is gaining a
false belief or at least losing a true
one if we were merely fall into doubt
and this is something that we do not
want then we may conclude a should
resolve not to be influenced by any
evidence against P notice that there are
two ways in which one can make this
resolution in the first place
one can resolve not to look at any
alleged evidence against fee for example
I might resolve not to read books of a
certain type that I know might contain
this misleading evidence I think that in
practice this is the most important case
in the second case one could resolve
that even was faced regardless of
whether one want in it with particular
evidence against P one when should
nevertheless ignore it since what knows
that it must be misleading given that
one knows that P we who were not
dogmatist may not have these attitudes
but I yo wanted to mention especially in
the first type of place of the
resolution of course various political
and religious leaders some of them may
not really think that we know that P but
some of them do and in both cases they
may simply try to prevent the public
from seeing yep the alleged if it
against against P where P is something
that they know is true
and you know there's such evidence is
misleading so they might try to prevent
people from ever seeing it the second
case is a little different from the
first because one is forced to see the
alleged evidence right now neither of
these things seem to be our attitude in
our non non dogmatic attitude towards
future evidence in cases where we know
something so there must be something
else wrong and this is the question what
is wrong okay and I mean and we'll
continue with some reservation about
this being wrong the pile of can be
stated as a question right if we know
that p why should we consider any
evidence against p what's always just
saying is that there might be certain
cases with where the attitude of the
dogmatist
is okay or needed let P be something
like I don't know the principle of
attraction or I don't know that Elvis is
alive that we know that is false right
and the principle of attraction is false
in those cases there seems to be reasons
for me to actually take this attitude of
not consider any evidence against P what
you were saying that this is not the
attitude that we have I think that
implicitly we do have this attitude
because we can't really be testing all
things that we know continuously right
we are finite beings and there are
things that we just ignore don't look at
the newspapers let's say that this is
alive
you get the sense that we should keep an
open attitude and always allow evidence
against our believes it makes sense and
in certain cases we do not keep this
open attitude right now the problem is
how we find a principled way to tell the
cases apart one thing that one can think
is that if you take this attitude and in
the cases where it is warranted perhaps
then you will sleep also in the cases
where it's not so warranty so you should
stay away from that given that we are
finite beings it's almost as needed that
we take this attitude in certain cases
now I really know I I'm myself
mentioned I mean I think I quote Steven
Weinberg saying that he hasn't read
literature thinking advocating that
astrology or necromancy or witchcraft
and I myself once encountered something
by someone reasonably well known in this
country or he was right purporting to to
argue for the theories of a certain
French astrologer and just a sock well
this why would I have to be punished for
knowing that B and having to go
everything stays you know no actually
many philosophers have replied to this
and dogmatism pile of that's all
invented and try to solve it and but one
of the problems with the solutions that
they give is that they usually take it
to be the case that is not a resolution
that you make in advance it's a
resolution that you make later on once
you show you already confronted the
evidence and in that case you may have
lost already your confidence in Peoria
you may start doubting it or remaining
it's making resolution not to look at
any such evidence so one is not
confronted with it right the solution is
not as some have argued
that once here you see the evidence
against P you no longer know it because
you've fallen into doubt because the
thing is to try to avoid if we're
getting into such a situation you know
that the alleged evidence will be
misleading think that taking the dom
artist after - in this case will show
some failure of the ancient being you
know reliable III don't think that I
should be consider in some sense shady
for taking this attitude I should I
think that I should be commended for
taking this idea yes well I know it only
because I take it it would be rational
for a nation to take this attitude yes
but from the perspective of the Asian
herself there will be a different a
different position because if you'll
argue that you need to know that you
know that be to be warranty in this
entity but from the perspective of the
first person right but that's a
different question the idea is when we
analyze that we think that it does make
sense and to take this attitude for a
nation to take this attitude they won't
be rational right other cases it would
be considered irrational and it is not
so easy on the basis of this kind of
argument to differentiate it's a possum
I think it's interesting
and thinking that their limitations that
we have to acknowledge and because of
that we have to take attitudes I mean we
are not coming the war in all cases but
in certain cases our warranty it's just
because we are finite beings yes yes
we're not really infallible oh so you
actually maybe it's yeah right always I
think there's almost leave you yes yeah
yes Wow
yeah well I mean in some cases one just
should not worry about looking at
supposed evidence against some things I
think that you making the paper is that
these dialogues would seem to lead
either to skepticism and think that
there is no knowledge yeah and of course
that's not right right or how the whole
thing is about to talk mr. attitude so
that's but of course if no one knows
anything right that would be another
type of resolution right at least as
long as this is about knowledge right
right and that would be complete
skepticism which has probably been I
don't know if anyone who's advocated
that actually and complete philosophical
skepticism that in the opposite would be
the dog
[Music]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you